let's try instead the nine one four
who's calling today from nine one four
damn in Westchester New York how are you
I've been better
you know I was somebody who Biden was
not my first choice in fact he was my
last choice right of all the of all the
opportunities of people to go with but
I'm sorry I I just don't see how
anything matters anymore at this point
with what we're going through I think
where I am now I'm about 40 minutes
north of New Rochelle okay so we're
pretty close to the epicenter of one of
the largest breakouts in the United
States yeah and I just can't see how
anything else with somebody who you know
has a family I have a seven-year-old son
now who his entire world is flipped
upside down and you think about the
world that we're leaving our kids where
they have lockdown drills and now
there's going to be probably virus
procedures to go through and it's just
it's just really really sad and I know
that you know Bernie Sanders is a more
ideal candidate for a good amount of
your viewers and listeners and and
myself as well but the guy in charge
right now sucks so bad and it's such a
monster yes to this country into the
world that it can't I can't even imagine
how anybody who is remotely a liberal or
a Democrat or a progressive how it's
even a thought in your mind like you
have to put your whole effort into Biden
at this point
yeah I get you know I hear you and this
listen this is we're all going to
remember you know life before this virus
thing and life after and it's going to
change a lot of things for a lot of
people not everybody's going to make it
just mathematically that's the reality
and one of the things I'm noticing is
that faced with the virus
things like the primaries and arguing
about Bernie versus Biden and stuff like
that it's becoming very backseat for a
lot of people and the thing is I get it
but we also don't want to lose the the
sort of the thread the plot which is
we've got to get Trump out because it's
hard to imagine a worse person and yet
it's hard to do electoral politics when
we're trying to figure out how can we
stop the transmission of this virus
absolutely and again I'm the person I'm
the kind of person that thinks that
Bernie Sanders is a thousand percent on
the money when it comes to health care
right and a lot of of his other ideas I
think are exactly where we need to go
but you know this is such a unfortunate
and life-or-death situation yep that
this is this is the the threats that
people were talking about you know it's
the threat that we've been talking about
with with with the changing environment
with climate change that that's going to
eventually affect us in the in the next
few years and we're going to have these
similar conversations about you know why
didn't we make the necessary changes
when we could write the kind of the kind
of drastic changes that we're doing now
with hunkering down is the same kind of
things we need to do with climate change
and that isn't going to happen with this
with this guy in charge at all right and
it's not going to happen with these with
these Republicans in power either that
they're just dishonest gules
and we need to all come together and
realize that that we're we're leaving a
hole for our kids to grow up in an
environment where we we either you know
had to swallow the choice of going with
a guy that is not our ideal candidate we
do not agree with on the majority of
issues with but we can agree with that
he's not Trump right and he will do it
maybe something different right right
right right yeah this this is not a
drill it becomes very real very quickly
I think is the point you're making very
lucidly dan I appreciate the call and
stay
safe up there in uh in Westchester thank
you very much and keep up the good work
alright great to hear from you that does
do it for calls today I know a lot of
people wanted wanted to get on we have
35 people holding but we we did what we
could we will take a break and we will
speak to you very very soon if you
weren't able to get on today